- I'm so straight.
(upbeat music)
- This is Ken, and I'm
gonna drag this bitch up.
I brought my own shit
because I like to cheat.
All right, here we go.
We're gonna put some lips on you.
- And I like that he
comes pre-tucked already.
- I know what we need to do.
- Ken is sporting the new
pom pom merkin collection.
- Oh, that's probably workin', right?
- I wish I had lashes for you.
That's okay, I'm how about we make some
lashes out of this old dress.
- I'm gonna give him
just a hint of clothes.
He goes to the Willam
Belli school of drag.
- This is very couture, you can't do this.
This is the stuff that
Gotye got fired for.
- Funny that you just
put a little eye shadow
on Ken and suddenly, he's a woman.
- This blue marker, when
you put somethin' blue
around your eyes it lets
people know you swallow.
(gasps)
Flawless.
- I'm kind of going for a Jem and the
Holograms kind of thing.
- Does super glue work on metal?
You sounded confident.
(laughing behind camera)
- We'll fasten it with some safety pins
and tape and a dream, and
you're good to go, honey.
- You're gonna go to the dance.
Mommy's gonna get you together real quick.
She'll fix your dress.
- Bloop.
Oh wait, one boob is
bigger than the other.
It's a more natural look.
- I'm so pretty.
(upbeat music)
- He goes by Vegina King.
Vegina's just starting out.
She's a 19 year old baby
drag queen, and she's learned
all of her makeup tips
from YouTube tutorials.
She's a combination of
Trixie Mattel and Ongina.
- This is my doll.
Her name is Caitlyn Dolezal.
The drag doll's inspiration is she
whips her hair back and forth.
Her style is just, very
Dolezal, very f-ed up,
like, that's not right.
- My name is Lenny McBottoms, yeah.
My inspiration is Jem and Ronald McDonald.
I'm flipping you off right
now, but you can't tell.
Anybody have a dollar?
Anybody?
(percussive music)
- This was a really fun challenge.
- With the dolls it's
the same problem with
some queens, their feet are real big.
- They're so booked, you don't even know,
they're so in demand, they're like, forget
Willam and and Manila
and Pandora, these girls.
- I think a drag queen always
remembers her first drag
mother, so I they will remember us,
because my drag queen doll
stole some of my costumes.
She mopped that right out of my drag bag.
- That's how you get to know a girl,
you go through her s--t
while she's onstage.
- I got my boy pockets
filled in in Central Florida.
- You look real natural too, honey.
- Thanks, the work is soft.
They said beauty is in milimeters.
(laughing)